So my very first job as a rookie was to, as soon
as we got to miko was to get unstrapped out of my
seat, float down to a locker by me, get the
proper camera out, float up to the overhead
window while Dick Richards the commander on
my first flight, was pitching discovery over
on its back so that we could take a picture of
this tank as it's following away back to earth.
Well, I floated up to the overhead window and
I'm looking outside and Dick says, Hey Bruce,
you should be seeing it. And I said, yeah,
Dick, I do. It's awesome. It's beautiful.
He said, well, why aren't you taking any
pictures? I said, pictures of what? Oh,
the tank. I was so blown away by seeing Earth
for the first time that I choked on my first
job and I was supposed to have this great big
picture of the tank. Well, by the time I took
a picture of the tank, it was like falling
away from us, but it was just beautiful. It
was just seeing the earth for the first time from
space is probably my most memorable experience.
For the full story watch the first episode
of the insane engineering of the
space shuttle on our channel now